hey, how's it hanging
take a closer look at those billboards
the numbers represent that the Marvel
Cinematic Universe phases one through
three are now complete Marvel Studios is
excited to show you what comes next
you're gonna love this these villains
that we now have in our universe happen
to be characters that are in the
sinister six there may be something that
happens with that no matter where he
goes the world is gonna be different for
him here's the real blockbuster brace
yourselves you might want to sit out
spider-man's name is Peter Parker what
the no more hiding yeah no more hiding
one of I think our great hopes for
future films is other articulations of
denim as fans the comics will no
Carnage's the bond between Cletus Kasady
a serial and the red symbiote and
so this movie will introduce Cletus
Kasady hi Eddie carnage is the promise
of the venom character taken to the next
level so you know going into venom you
were hoping that there'd be carnage and
they delivered in a very delightful way
that made you go alright I'll give you
more of my money if you do this again
welcome back everyone is Charlie we have
a whole bunch of new spider-man vs the
sinister six and venom to talk about we
got a clip of Amy Pascal talking about
their plans for sinister six movie I
think we all assumed it was going to
happen so we'll break that down and
because of all the news of spider-man
coming back into the MCU we got official
details from Sony and Marvel on how they
plan on connecting the universes because
as Kevin Feige said spider-man the only
character that can jump between
cinematic universes they actually do
have a plan for connecting the venom
movies and those spin-offs to the
spider-man MCU movies but it gets really
technical with the way they describe it
so I'll talk about that later in the
video we're doing a giveaway for the
spider-man far from home blu-ray all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your best theory about
spider-man vs the sinister six in venom
on the video so during the spider-man
far from home bonus features there's a
scene of Amy Pascal talking about the
sinister six movie within the spider-man
marvel movies they've done so far in a
very direct quote is there maybe
something that happens with that meaning
of course something is going to happen
with the sinister six because she
wouldn't say that in an edited segment
for the bonus features if they didn't
plan on doing it at some point
this isn't commentary on the movie this
is them doing a special featurette
talking about the future of spider-man
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
previously I think that everyone just
assumed from the villains that they've
been using in that spider-man homecoming
post-credit scene with the Scorpion
talking about teaming up to kill
spider-man that we'd see an MCU version
of sinister six that would be different
from Sony's taken those characters
during the Andrew Garfield amazing
spider-man movies then you have the
venom crew talking about all the
different versions of venom that they
plan on doing now that Sony has
officially confirmed Tom Hollands
spider-man venom crossover obviously
that gets into spider-man wearing the
symbiote in the maximum carnage movie
with spider-man and venom teaming up
against carnage but any Pascal even
suggest that Mysterio isn't dead at the
end of the movie she kind of hints at
that but part of their reason for being
so ambiguous about it it was to give
themselves an out in case Jake
Gyllenhaal can't come back for another
movie for their big sinister six team-up
or they just straight-up decide to not
use Mysterio but I don't know why they
wouldn't
everybody loved Jake Gyllenhaal so much
and he was fantastic as that character
why wouldn't you bring him back for a
big team-up but given all the issues
that Marvel and Sony have had since the
summer it's funny to think that this was
Marvel
plan and Sony's plan all along for these
characters to build up to a new
spider-man verse the sinister sixth
movie the new sharing contract that
Marvel just signed with Sony is only for
two more movies though it's spider-man 3
which they're starting pre-production on
really soon and shooting later in 2020
then Marvel gets to use spider-man in
one other Marvel phase four movie or one
of the Disney Plus series I assume it
will be a movie they would want to go
with the biggest possible audience
normally I would say that that second
movie they would put him in would be
Avengers 5 but because spider-man 3 is
coming out July 2021 and Avengers 5
isn't coming out until 2023 at the
earliest that other Spider Man crossover
might happen in one of the other big
Marvel phase 4 movies like Thor 4 maybe
Falcon and Winter Soldier maybe Moon
Knight or even black panther 2 the way
Kevin Feige spoke about Marvel phase 4
at the Comic Con panel made it sound
like it would be a little bit shorter in
duration than previous phases in Marvel
phase 5 would be the big dawn of mutants
x-men Deadpool in Fantastic Four
characters in the MCU it would be kind
of weird for Marvel to wait for their
second spider-man appearance to that
Marvel phase 5 starting in 2023 or which
every year they officially want to begin
Marvel phase 5 the reason why I say
Avengers 5 probably isn't gonna happen
until 2023 is because they already gave
Black Panther 2 that plush may release
date in 2022 in all their Avengers
movies have been that late April early
May releases 2023 is just the next May
that's available after black panther 2
and 2023 is the current year in the MCU
post avengers endgame
but here's another sweet detail that we
got because of all the Marvel Sony
fighting last month is that Sony
secretly had plans for two more Tom
Hollands spider-man films they didn't
say what that fourth one was spider-man
3 the way the director was talking about
it before their big break up would just
be a craven movie he's an OG sinister 6
character and with him that makes 6
characters who have been members of the
sinister six team of various points so
they have their team-up after spider-man
3 their original plan might have just
been to use spider-man 4 as spider-man
versed the sinister six but there's no
date on that movie yet we only know
spider-man 3 is coming out 2021 but that
would mean that if Kevin Feige and
Marvel wants to make that sinister six
film in the MCU they need to
new sharing arrangement after spider-man
3 and whatever that other spider-man
crossover film winds up being inside the
MCU
otherwise the sinister six would just be
a pure Sony movie and say like 2023 two
years after spider-man 3 but where is
the venom crossover in this timeline
venom 2 scheduled to come out next
October they're shooting it in November
right now they'll do their carnage film
here's the not so secret details on how
Marvel and Sony intend on connecting the
MCU with the venom verse movies it's not
quite as complicated as it sounds but it
does get a little technical they're
referring to it as a call and answer
relationship where in the future beyond
spider-man 3 when spider-man has already
crossed over with venom they've started
to do their sinister six movie in
spider-man has already done stuff inside
the venom first movies that when he
comes back into a Marvel movie they will
loosely reference the events of what
happened in the plot of those venom
movies in Sony will do the same thing
for all the MCU spider-man films so
spider-man has this great history in the
Marvel films going back to Captain
America Civil War
they´ll loosely refer to plot points
from all those movies Tony Stark the
glasses that he gave it would happen
with Mysterio when he crosses over with
venom inside the venom movies I know
this raises a lot of questions about
them canonizing venom within the MCU
but the way they talk about it makes it
sound like it'll be an easter-egg
relationship only so it will explain how
spider-man in venom can team up inside
New York City and it can still be the
version of New York City that we see
during spider-man far from home but you
don't have a bunch of Avengers flying
around asking about this venom and
carnage character it can just be a
Spider Man adventure where they loosely
reference stuff from The Avengers movies
but it's not them saying that venom is
gonna show up in Avengers 5 or anything
like that
that would be them officially canonizing
venom to the MCU the reason why New York
City is so important is because it seems
like they're filming venom 2 to look
like it's happening in New York City in
the Morbius movie which is kind of a
spin-off of venom right now is also
supposed to take place in New York City
so Sony really wants its venom verse to
take place in and around where
spider-man would normally be so
hopefully that explains a little bit
more about how they're planning on
handling venom inside the MCU as of
right now the sinister six characters
they have are scorpion and vulture who
are still in prison / that
post-credits scene the Shocker was also
arrested after spider-man defeated him
during spider-man homecoming at the
dance so even though it wasn't shown in
the post-credits scene he's in jail -
Mysterio is currently chilling on the DL
believed to be dead temporarily in Aaron
Davis aka the Prowler uncle - Miles
Morales in the MCU is still free and
clear running around New York City in
Queens you also probably heard the news
recently about how Tom Holland is being
credited with helping them close the New
Deal for bringing spider-man back into
the MCU obviously he didn't do it all by
himself but there was a funny clip a
little while ago with the CEO of Disney
Bob Iger talking about Tom Hahn he even
makes fun of him just a little bit and
he said something on stage it was clear
that the fans wanted Tom back as
spider-man yes it was made by Marvel and
our Marvel production team right and
after d23 Tom reached out to folks who
work for me said could I please have
Bob's email address or phone number of
course I'm very protected so they were
very careful and I said sure I have him
have him contact me and he did we spoke
and he basically made it he cried on the
phone really no not really that he cared
so much actually we care a lot about him
he's a great spider-man he's the best
father I felt actually I felt for him
and it was clear that the fans wanted
all this to happen so after I got off
the phone with him I made a couple of
phone calls to our team at the Disney
Studios and then I decided to call the
head of Sony and I said we have to get
we got to figure out a way to get this
done for Tom and for the fans like -
divorced parents and we did they just
him acknowledging the fact that a lot of
the money people at both of these
companies stopped thinking about the
actual people that were involved in this
deal and how it would hurt the fans Tom
Hollands phone call just reminded him of
that but if you have any big questions
about what's going on with venom
spider-man crossover or venom in the MCU
just post it on the video below in all
your theories about when they're gonna
finally do their sinister six movie that
they keep hyping up so much thank you
very much Amy Pascal happen to be care
characters that are in the sinister six
there may be something that happens in
that
congratulations Roberto Mattos here the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
Deadpool video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details everybody click here for
that new Deadpool 3 Robot Chicken teaser
trailer and click here for that brand
new Avengers infinity saga trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome
I'll see you guys tonight